alors demain ce nouveau conseil régional
va donc se réunir pour la première fois
un conseil régional issu et c'est une
première aussi du suffrage direct et qui
dispose de compétences nouvelles puisque
la loi de décentralisation si j'ose dire
l'y oblige
exc alors si on les bureaux de des
nouveaux conseillers un certain nombre
de dossiers des dossiers jean-pierre
enquiries qui sont prioritaires dès
l'origine les compétences des conseils
régionaux apparaissent comme multiples
jugés 'sans développement économique
social sanitaire culturel scientifique
de plus aménagement du territoire
régional et préservation de son identité
la loi de décentralisation en ajoute
deux la formation professionnelle la
gestion des lycées
le conseil régional d'île de france
possède pour sa part deux compétences
spécifiques les espaces verts et la
politique des transports
mais il est vrai que cette dernière n'a
encore jamais pu être exercées faute de
textes législatifs depuis le 17 mars le
conseil régional n'est plus un
établissement public mais une
collectivité territoriale
essentiellement cela signifie que son
fonctionnement sera calqué sur celui des
assemblées départementales des conseils
généraux pas de grande révolution à
attendre
quant aux gros dossiers sur lesquels le
conseil va avoir dès demain à se pencher
là encore rien de fondamentalement
nouveau poursuite de l'a86 achèvement
des bills nouvelle adaptation de la
formation professionnelle à l'emploi
restauration et construction du lycée
sans oublier disneyland à marne la
vallée